welcome back everybody we're here with
the amazing Hillary Duff and we just
talked about playing Y2K yay or nay a
game about the early 2000s and like
should we yay it and bring it back or
nay it and like leave it in the past I
mean have you walked into in the Urban
Outfitters lately you know what I think
they have our pictures up in the like in
the
creation room and be thrilled I love %
are I'm an urban girl I'll take it um
but I remember like in the '90s the' 7s
were really hot and now it's 20 years
later and the Y2K is all the rage it's
all it's all full circle all right um
we're going to decide um in Y2K yay or
nay if it should stay or go there we
go um okay here are two moments that we
both lived um we'll put them up side by
side um the
this I mean look at us you look so much
cooler than me I don't agree with that
at all why your look so good you guys my
hair color who did that all over color
to me well yay or nay should we have
like and by the way I don't even know if
that's a skinny scarf but it's certainly
a Bejeweled skinny scarf those scarves
are both giving yeah I know I say yay I
I say yay
too wa
anyone have a skinny starp no one I feel
like you should vote on this in your
pink sweater with the daisies on them
sir oh my go you're really cute
ironically this is about a sweater
Poncho that both Hillary and I rocked um
back in the
day sir what's your name Angel Angel my
name is Angel nice to meet you okay uh
is this a yay or nay for you I'm saying
yes yay wow I have to politely disagree
well I did pick you for your sweater
choices why would you n it okay yours
for me is better because you're wearing
less under it what am I wearing under
mine I I do it was really cold that day
I was bundled
[Music]
up